[Music]
foreign
the strikes on Ukraine's Capital started
early on the ground people felt the
explosions
in the sky they could see the attackers
one so-called Kamikaze drone approaches
its Target as kiev's air defense systems
attempt to shoot it down
rescue teams were quick to arrive in the
Chevrolet District
firefighters hosing down smoked ruins as
people who'd taken shelter emerged from
underground
Target destroyed the whole
infrastructure of Ukraine destroyed the
infrastructure Hometown they left people
freezing in the winter less people do it
without electricity they need the
Russians who want to make the
humanitarian catastrophe in our hometown
and also at the same time destroy the
buildings
people's homes were destroyed
behind me is the residential building
that was damaged in the Drone attack
this morning now this neighborhood also
has important infrastructure sites in it
and was hit by Russian missiles last
week Airaid Sirens may have stopped
sounding but local officials say
residents should still avoid the area
for now
many injured people like this woman were
rescued
but others including a pregnant woman
and her husband were killed
you were in the room when the blast
started we then go out and see the
staircase is gone all gone to the ground
floor he waited for alarm to be called
off we were laying on the floor
firefighters came and they used a ladder
to rescue Us One By One Vision ran to
the shelter in that building it was
horrible
many here worry about how quickly they
can reach safety
there is no shelter around the closest
in a 10 minutes run from here we decided
to stay home you might be running on the
street and the particles would hurt you
then as if On Cue the air raid sirens
ring out again
all of us should probably go to the
shelter because this is their target
people's constant concern now if and
when this area may be targeted again
foreign